dog found an insane trick against Frank
predicted by Ludwig to secure victory in
POG Champs the underdog Frank defied the
odds by winning the first game
one and Sea Dog quickly bounced back to
win the second game game three was full
of excitement with Frank getting the
advantage early on finding a great 15th
move with D3 oh my God that's your guy
after Frank expertly followed up with
Knight C2 forking the white Rooks Sea
Dog tried for a Hail Mary Bishop H6 for
white
and it worked Frank took what appeared
to be a free Bishop walking into a royal
Fork converting from here was simply a
matter of technique for Sea Dog leaving
Frank completely demoralized up 2-1
going into the final game Sea Dog
confidently won that game as well
cementing his place in pogchamp's
history